hello everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
year 12 of Abby's kitchen honestly
[Music]
oh my God like never in my wildest
dreams would I think that I would spend
over a decade making content for all of
you guys I am so grateful for what I get
to do every day but yeah I was just in
the content Vault and realized that I
have been on YouTube since
2011 and I posted almost 4 000 videos 4
000 videos you know how many hours of
looking at my face that means for my
poor editors Brody I'm so sorry you've
seen it all next I feel like we need to
do a reel of all the behind the scenes
moments that he sees in between the good
takes a lot of I'm sure oh for God's
sakes there's the first one but anyway
while I've been making videos casually
since 2011 things really took off for me
when I gave my thoughts on a certain all
fruit what I eat in a day video five
years ago when I was pregnant with my
first and then after that these kind of
what a day dietitian review videos
became my signature format which means
that a huge chunk of those near 4 000
videos are reactions to disorderly or
dangerous tips and misinformation online
so I thought I would share a few kind of
memorable moments from The Vault things
that have stuck with me and that's
saying a lot like I've seen a lot and
honestly I can't even tell you how hard
it was to choose like I could make
easily another 4 000 videos of all these
highlights or I guess low lights in this
case so if you want more leave me a
comment below
[Music]
but please check out my trigger warning
folks if you've ever found my content
triggering today is gonna take the cake
it's like a triggering smorgasbord here
folks so please be kind to yourself no
joke also a big reminder that this
content isn't necessarily fresh so a lot
of these content creators or celebrities
may have grown in their food Journeys
and ultimately we hope that they have
but it's a gentle reminder of the
permanency of the internet and why we
need to be prudent about what we Post
online especially if we hold a lot of
power and Cloud also don't forget to hit
up my description for my free Hunger
crushing combo ebook and a link to my
ltk page to see what I'm wearing today
okay but let me hop in here quickly to
discuss my sponsor today neuro hacker so
if you've been following my content you
know that since becoming a mom my memory
has been in rough shape I constantly
feel like I'm grasping onto this like
faint memory to do something just just
as I'm letting go of another so I've
been really invested in a brain
supporting diet and supplement regimen
and I've just recently started taking
qualia mind as you guys know I am super
picky about supplements too often
supplement companies pack a bunch of
great sounding ingredients into
proprietary Blends that offer subpar
doses that ultimately will never yield
results but neuro hacker products are
all third party tested and are
formulated based on scientific evidence
for the Goldilocks zones for dosages
with all their data and research
published for transparency online their
qualia mind is a combination of
nootropics antioxidants adaptogens and
unique vitamins and nutrients that have
specific brain supporting functions for
daily mental performance and for
long-term brain health I've talked a lot
about the benefits of nootropics and
adaptogens on my channel and as I myself
have become more invested in my own
brain health this is something that I've
actually found is moving the knee needle
and for a greater focus on long-term
brain health their synolytic formula
helps to clean up senescent cells that
contribute to premature aging their
products are also non-GMO vegan and
gluten free and they're backed by a
100-day money-back guarantee for you to
see how they work for you so if you want
to try out neuro hacker yourself go to
neurohacker.com
Abby for 100 off and as one of my
subscribers you can use my code Abby at
checkout for an additional 50 off of
your first purchase and I want to know
in the comments how it's affected your
cognitive Health all right first up
Victoria Beckham unfortunately I'm
married to someone that has eaten the
same thing for the last 25 years since
since I've met Victoria she she only ate
you know grilled fish steamed vegetables
she'll very rarely deviate away from
there the only time that she's ever
probably shared something that's been on
my plate was actually when she was
pregnant with Harvard seem and it was
the most amazing thing it was it was my
one of my favorite evenings I can't
remember what it was but I know that
she's not eating it since
so this this actually breaks my heart
now aside from the fact that I would
legit do anything anything to share a
meal with David Beckham sounds like an
adventure I'm in this absolutely
triggers memories of my own Ed days and
the impact that my rigidity had on
others not surprisingly this comment
resulted in dozens of Articles
suggesting that Victoria has an Edie
herself and while I'm not diagnosing
anyone I would say that generally
exclusively relying on a small number of
safe foods and avoiding shared family
meals is a common disordered eating red
flag from a nutrient perspective we're
ultimately talking about pretty much the
lowest calorie options available little
to no fat little to no carbs just low
calorie vegetables and lean protein
limited diet diversity risks nutritional
deficiencies and malnutrition and can
disadvantage a healthy gut microbiome as
well it also clearly puts a strain on
social interactions and relationships
and I specifically worry about the
impact on their observing children
especially their daughter Harper yeah I
still do worry about the kids but let's
switch gears here and talk about Kelly
Ripa and the video that was eventually
taken down Ashley her team emailed me as
well asking me to take my videos down
with some kind of fabrication about how
you know this diet recall was actually a
cleanse and not how she ate every single
day for 365 days of a year even though
she clearly stated that in the interview
but anyways
so many problematic moments let's take a
look at one of them what I will indulge
in is like a delicious chocolate covered
almond or chocolate covered cashew some
sort of like so I still feel like
there's something healthy in there I
mean her definition of a treat is a
chocolate almond or cashew or it's chia
pudding with some cocoa powder mixed in
so she says when she does treat herself
it has to be something that still feels
like it has something healthy in it so
she feels good about that choice maybe
this is sustainable for Kelly as I think
it's just kind of like a type A
personality thing but it would probably
be really unsustainable for a lot of
people long term and those cheat days
would probably get completely out of
control and speaking of accidentally
getting out of control let's turn it
over to former Cheetah Girl Adrian from
All Things Adrian I went
to briefing and I came back hungry and
it's in moments like this that I have a
few ideas of how you can curb a craving
I have a sweet craving right now is what
I'm craving I'm gonna try to just chug
an entire bottle of water because that
makes me feel full and then I don't have
my craving anymore don't give in to the
craving listen to me watch this Focus
self-discipline I tell myself self-love
is self-discipline and I'm going to chug
this entire thing
whoa okay well where to start so for
snack time Adrian is hungry not
surprisingly as she hasn't eaten much
today but instead of giving into her
Cravings she has a big jug of water I
can see why you guys flagged this video
for me to review Adrian claims that this
is kind of her diet hack to help her
feel full and encourages her fans to
listen to her and to not give in to
their cravings and instead just chug
some calorie-free water her rationale is
that the best Act of self-love is
self-discipline that is so wrong the
only appropriate self-loving response to
your body's legitimate need for food is
food and specifically food that is safe
culturally appropriate and enjoyable
this is a human right self-discipline at
the expense of meeting your body's needs
is the opposite of of self-love I'm kind
of mad that she even had to say that I'm
still mad I'm not gonna lie but I'm
probably a lot more disturbed by this
K-pop diet Insight so 27 year old IU AKA
Li G Yoon eats an Apple for breakfast a
sweet potato for lunch and a protein
shake for dinner that is literally just
over 300 calories for this entire day
that is less than half of what my six
month old baby needs and he's literally
a stationary blob but according to my
calculations a young girl like Lee who
is dancing and performing at this level
should be consuming well over 3 000
calories this breakfast lunch and dinner
combo is just like one small meals worth
of food and not even a complete meal at
that as there's literally no fat here at
all and speaking of no fat get ready for
this one from healthy Emmy pounds of
potatoes which is about 700 calories and
then about 77 calories for the broccoli
so that comes out to 777 calories I
don't really know where to start here
I'm not even sure how you do a beauty
hero shot of a plate like that I
personally would have a hard time with
that creatively speaking
um but anyways this meal is pretty
consistent with what we've seen from
Emmy's recipes so far no fat no
seasoning very carb heavy it's a
substantially larger portion than what
would be considered normal for one meal
this meal is also again very high in
fiber at 30 grams which is enough to
meet an individual's fiber needs for an
entire day but one thing I do want to
highlight about this meal is the protein
content so far we've seen that Emmy's
recipes are either very low in protein
or the protein content comes from large
quantities of beans oats or nutritional
yeast in this case despite not having a
traditional or complete protein Source
this recipe actually provides 30 grams
of protein which is considered an
appropriate amount of protein for one
meal and while broccoli and potatoes
naturally contain some amount of protein
you would need to eat very large
quantities of these Foods in order to
meet your protein needs most people
would have a really hard time with that
myself included and since we're on the
topic of protein-free plant-based meals
let's take a look at this moment from
Ian Somerhalder you know you can take
one big head of lettuce cut it up put it
in a cast iron pan water and salt cook
it down a bit lettuce like cooked or raw
is not a good vegan meal it's like when
you go to a wedding and check off the
vegan entree option and you are
literally just given a plate of whatever
side vegetables everyone else is getting
with their meat I mean at least things
like carrots and potatoes would yield
some Trace protein and fiber but lettuce
not so much I'm freaking hungry serve
that lettuce with some tofu or chickpeas
or lentils or something else but uh and
while I could literally go on all day
with these clips there are really so
many more I haven't even touched on
let's finish off with this regrettably
Unforgettable moment from hrh Collective
first of all you shouldn't be eating
after eight if you're trying to lose
weight do not eat after eight like
kitchen is closed after eight no if you
could if you're dying I told you I've
showed you guys what the options are if
you're not blocked you stop 10 calorie
Jello it's like string beans string
beans or something and like cherry
tomatoes like like a jalapeno like a
pickle like a like a tiny pickle like
something like that like no you're not
eating anymore I'm also going to talk
about going to bed hungry you guys are
gonna kill me I don't give it by the way
I'm not probably holding a gun to your
head and I'm not like if you don't want
like I can't even look like oh my God
you're like an influencer you shouldn't
be saying things that like first of all
you're not gonna die from this you're
gonna like look better so shut up so
like if you're dying then you can have a
10 calorie pack of jello like I am
totally aware that some people feel they
need to have some kind of guidelines or
structure with their eating and that is
totally okay that is one thing but
Alexander is actively telling you to
ignore your body's screaming hunger cues
which are designed to help you fuel your
body right I'm getting mad oh my God
obviously this type of eating is not
sustainable and it sounds pretty damn
miserable if you ask me I mean your body
is literally begging you to eat to the
point that you you're excited about
eating some string beans and two
cherry tomatoes that is a good sign that
you should respect those cues and give
it the fuel that's asking for before you
do some serious metabolic and
psychological damage guys I'm honestly
still not sure if she's just trolling
all of us or if this is real life but
let me know in the comments what you
guys actually think so if you guys want
to watch the full episodes from these
clips I'm going to be linking to them
below and if you want a whole other
Roundup like this also let me know below
but I hope this little compilation
serves as a good reminder of how
problematic and toxic the internet can
be when it comes to messages around food
like I just pulled together some really
dangerous ones here but there are so so
many more and when I see them all pulled
together like this I'm like holy
are are the kids gonna be all right
I've been free
there's a lot of work to be done clearly
and even though a lot of these videos
are old and maybe no longer reflect the
viewpoints of these creators or
celebrities again it's a good reminder
of the responsibility that we all have
for the content that we put out there
even if you're not a celebrity or even a
content creator and you're just a
regular person on Tick Tock same thing a
lot of vulnerable people might watch a
video that's from four years ago that
still served in the algorithm because it
has millions of views and despite having
no context whatsoever just kind of latch
on to whatever tips or suggestions that
were shared back then but anyways guys
that's all for today if you like this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
leave me a comment below and also hit up
my description for a free Hunger crush
and combo ebook for some actual balanced
nutrition advice and suggestions and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
laughs
[Music]